je vais commencer d'une manière un petit
peu impertinentes avec cette affaire
zahia procès aujourd'hui on a un peu
l'impression que pour vous pour beaucoup
de gens mais kader qui ont été marqués
par le féminisme on se retrouve avec une
sorte de féminisme inversé c'est
maintenant vous avez car la guerre
faible isabelle adjani qui chantent ses
louanges aurait quand même très très
loin de simone de beauvoir mai puis les
choses se soient claires moi je ne veux
pas lancer la pierre à à zahia dans
l'absolu je trouve que le fait
qu'aujourd'hui elle se lance dans une
entreprise comme celle qu'elle a lancée
dans laquelle d'ailleurs elle a souvent
de bonnes idées notamment celles qu'elle
a eu récemment dû recourir aux ouvrières
de l'ex lejaby devenus les ateliers à
villeurbanne qui est elle même une très
belle entreprise
donc je trouve que cette aventure
entrepreneuriale était extrêmement
intéressante et qu'il faut la promouvoir
auprès d'un certain nombre de jeunes
filles qui se disent que l'entreprise
cette condamnation était logique pour
quelqu'un qui a pratiqué la prostitution
finalement elle a changé de vêtements
tels que zahia lorsqu'elle s'est
retrouvée dans cette affaire à laquelle
vous faites allusion était mineure dans
le ça n'est sûrement pas zahia que je
vais condamné pour s'être retrouvé dans
une telle affaire en revanche ce que je
dis c'est qu'elle a été victime des
faits d'ailleurs elle même lorsque vous
l'interrogez aujourd'hui elle vous dit
qu'elle souhaite surtout tourné la page
sur cette époque est ce que je dis moi
c'est que la société devrait ne plus
avoir les yeux brouillés par rapport à
ce type de chose la prostitution est une
violence en particulier lorsque s'exerce
sur des mineures mais même sur des
majeurs et donc il faut faire en sorte
de la faire reculer
mais pour revenir à ce qu'elle est
devenue aujourd'hui alors devant toi
elle s'est lancée c'est une chef
d'entreprise l'aventuré entreprenariale
moi je veux dire aujourd'hui c'est le
salon planète pme vous savez dans lequel
on va retrouver un certain nombre à la
fois de chefs d'entreprise et puis de
gens qui espèrent peut-être l'être un
jour je veux dire aux femmes en
particulier que c'est une aventure
formidable et que nous ferons tout dans
les pouvoirs publics pour les soutenir
dans cette démarche on a trop peu de
femmes qui s'engagent dans l'entreprise
à la création d'entreprise vous avez à
peine 30 % de femmes dans les créateurs
d'entreprise quand vous prenez les
entreprises innovantes c'est moins de
10% de femmes et c'est un véritable
manque à gagner à la fois pour elle et
pour notre société donc nous avons
décidé de développer
je l'annoncerai tout à l'heure d un
certain nombre de
mesures de soutien à la création
d'entreprise spécifiquement pour les
femmes car les femmes rencontrent des
problématiques particulières par exemple
en termes d'accès au crédit donc une
lançons un fonds de garantie à
l'initiative des femmes pour permettre
de soutenir cette création d'entreprise
par exemple en faisant en sorte que des
réseaux d'accompagnement se met en place
de façon efficace autour de ces femmes
pour résoudre des problèmes comme la
garde d'enfants pendant le moment où on
crée son entreprise etc et surtout nous
sensibilisons de manière générale les
jeunes filles en allant dans les
collèges dans les lycées dans
l'enseignement supérieur à cette
possibilité cette opportunité
professionnelle de créer une entreprise